hi everyone it's Joanna here
[Music]
hi guys it's Joanna here
and today's workout is called the new
base workout so that's it your male
intervals what body types you can only
use in one slice amazing gently 300
calories consume
make sure to bring low twist double leg
raises you spray and pushing yourself
three more okay remember breathing ten
more nice proper form don't rush the
workout look up reach down and up
breathe in and breathe out on my thighs
really reach up stress up
three two more
[Music]
and what I'll be doing in this video is
to actually fill my middle plan for a
day
it's delicious for you freshen salad
kimone design I think the basic idea
so these are few of my favorite Indian
dishes you will be hooked voila look at
that or even as a starter try all these
recipes with the right strategy and
tools it is that simple you should try
at home
some foods are more calorie dense
compared to others
[Applause]
is the frame to stop binge eating more
water really or searing we should and
can work out it can't stop overeating
and beautiful estrogen is due to stress
a good posture swinging back is bad for
your skin love for the first two weeks
we can touch going to the toilet our
breath just keep this in mind
[Applause]
[Music]
or if you want to
in the kitchen
had a lot of fun
try all these recipes out
are we excited
my dogs they're a huge part of my life
I see different people I explore
different species
Fitness is my lifestyle
[Music]
let me know how you felt in the comments
below all the best